my name is Edie Peck jr. and today I'm
going to be talking about narrow Yama's
cow problem which is similar to the
Fibonacci rabbit problem but a few
hundred years later
I'm ed Pegg jr. and I'm going to talk
about various algebraic numbers such as
narayana's cow so the basic idea is you
have some points and you move one of
them to the origin 0 0 you move another
to 1 0 and then you try to figure out
where the other points are and if
there's any nice pattern you can find
with them so here's an example of a of a
hard problem the sqe mal ESCO unit
distance graph all these edges yes
theoretically
all the edges in this graph are length 1
so this is a hard problem to solve so
one thing I found here with all these
constraint problems is number fields
were very useful for example this is an
object called the golem graph the the
haywood now but the chromatic number of
the the plane problem is you try to
color the plane and you don't want any
two points a unit distance apart to have
the same color and the question is how
many colors do you need well with a if
you have a triangle you know that you
need at least three different colors and
it's all three of those points or unit
distance apart with this object here if
you toss it on a plane you can show that
at least four colors are needed and
there's a construction that shows that
seven colors is enough to completely
color to the plane so that no two points
or you know distance apart so for a long
time the lower bound was four for the
number of colors and the upper bound was
seven and no one knew what the actual
value was and this is one of the graphs
that proves that it's at least seven so
we have these odd values for the
placements of other points we've got
zero and one but these two look weird
so how can we make these points better
well we've got square root of 33 so we
can try using two number field and it
doesn't work but if you square or the
object instead then you get this nice
value it's seven over 72 one over 72
so I started squaring these values and
this set of points here for something
called sacs triangle which I'll talk
discuss later on I found all these nasty
root objects if I squared all of them
and use two
number field everything turned into
these nice-looking triples so I wrote
these functions to basically square
objects and use two number field and for
the gone graph everything turns into
these nice doubles everything is nice
and smooth and if you reverse them you
get the original values back so I
started looking what other places is
this useful so here's the original graph
here with the algebraic coordinates
based on the square root of 33 so the
first thing missed algebraic field is
the golden ratio which was made famous
by Fibonacci so here's this original
text here 1 2 3
well actually I'm getting ahead of
myself here in order to understand the
Fibonacci rabbits you have to understand
Arabic numerals first which he did
produced a few pages before he
introduced the Fibonacci rabbits so this
is really an important book this is what
introduced Arabic numerals to Europe
this is a it's like David Tsing master
sent me these photographs from the
original book so you have this sequence
of numbers the Fibonacci sequence and
the convergence converge to the golden
ratio and those are useful for things
like building polyhedra all of these are
based on the golden ratio which lives in
the icosahedron group which is also
based on the golden ratio you can also
do other things with the golden ratio
like here's our first fractal here the
almond chair these numbers on the edges
here these are all powers of the square
root of the golden ratio so this is the
square root of the gold
ratio ^ v is the length of this edge so
you have this chair object divided into
two similar chair objects that have the
exact same ratios if you want to solve
the foreign align problem there's a
method with the golden ratio based on
points of the dodecahedron and its
intersection diagonal intersections for
the three and a line problem this was
recently solved by get remembers name
but there's there's four sporadic
solutions for this three no line problem
and here are three of them right here
all of them use the golden ratio and the
middle one here here are the points and
everything is based on powers of the
golden ratio and and combinations you
can use the golden rectangle an infinite
number of scaled copies of itself to get
something with the same area as the
original golden rectangle but you can't
actually exactly cover the golden
rectangle with golden rectangles one
thing you need you could do is use the
golden triangle instead but that scales
down really fast you can't really see
what's going on
another thing you do is Penrose tiles
which is this is not this is actually
the windham gara roof this is 3d and all
these roms are identical you can also do
the club surface there's 27 lines and
all of these points here are based on
golden ratio values so the golden ratio
is pretty powerful but I found that cow
was more powerful so the cow problem is
that a cow gives birth every year and
turned the calf gives birth to another
calf when it's three years old so this
is a problem from 1356 so you need this
polynomial here to solve the problem it
has a discriminant
- 31 which I'll discuss a little bit
later and the radical form of this is
terrifying but they it's approximately
one point four six and there's also the
complex values here so if you take it as
a linear recurrence you get the number
of cows this is the narrow yama cow
sequence and if you round cow you get
the same sequence now if you do
something called the chaos game where
you use the complex values as directions
and you pick them at random you wind up
getting this distribution of points when
you play the game on and on and you wind
up getting these fractal triangle like
objects well it turns out you can
directly build these fractal triangles
so we've got the whole thing and we've
got two sub copies which are identical
to the original fractal triangle and if
you look at the area ratios these are
them here they turn out to be exactly
powers of cow for their area ratios and
these are really weird tiling objects
here's how to build a nautilus with
fractal cow triangles which is something
I managed to come up with it never been
seen before so with the fractal with the
golden rectangle we weren't able to
build itself with that so are there
other values where you can have an
infinite series of scaled things which
add up to the original thing well these
are the values that might work these
this table here and it turns out yes you
can exactly cover the original Kal
triangle with an infinite number of
copies of itself and this is never been
seen either now the discriminant is the
product of the squares of the
differences of the roots and so that's
that here
for any of these algebraic numbers
there's many different polynomials which
basically give the same algebraic number
field so if you take the discriminant
you'll always get the same value so
that's a good way of knowing which field
you're in so here's two different
polynomials they're basically the same
thing they they wind up with different
values but they're discriminants are
both negative 31 so this is the cow
algebraic number field so another famous
one is based in the square root of 2
HIPPA this famous and then was killed
unfortunately because they didn't like
the fact that they proved it was
irrational
so a4 paper is based on the square root
of 2 if you fold it in half you get two
similar rectangles this is also the same
algebraic field used for making the
regular octagon and also all the
intersection points and here's how these
intersection points look as as tuples
within this algebraic number field you
can also divide a piece of a4 paper like
this which has never been seen before I
found this fall while trying to build
these rectangle constructions at us yeah
that's that's interesting and no one had
seen it before so this is a basically
complete list of squares and double
squares that all similar rectangles that
are similar to the a4 paper and this
scales up into three dimensions you take
a cuboid you cut it in half and you get
two similar cuboids to the original
cuboid this has never been published
before the first publication was this
toy called the fifth chair by Dale
Walton which he published a few years
ago and it looks like this you've got
this chair shaped object that's divided
into four other chair shaped objects
that are identical to it
similar to it and this was the first
time the Delian constant the cube root
of two got used for this particular
fractal issue now I defined many other
mathematicians who had solve this
problem themselves but they didn't think
it was it was a new thing so they all
just just let it sit in their notebooks
and I've there's at least 20 different
mathematicians that have found this well
there's cuboid up here that didn't
publish it so this this toy is probably
the first publication of this rather
amazing object so the next in this
series we've done the golden ratio and
the silver ratio the next we can
actually solve it's something based on
the square root of 13 it is the bronze
ratio which is a solution the best-known
solution for the ABC conjecture is used
right there if you look up ABC
congestion you'll find that this is the
best known example you can also use it
if you put eight points in a unit square
and you want the smallest triangle to be
as large as possible you have to use the
bronze constant and these two red lines
here they have a ratio to each other
that's exactly the bronze ratio now
another one of the really powerful ones
is the plastic constant and this this is
the one where I found the most solutions
in here's a way of dividing up a square
into three similar rectangles that all
have ratios based on the plastic
constant and the value is about 1.3 to 4
and it has a discriminative -23 so if
you hit a discriminative -23 when you're
using these techniques you know that
you're in plastic space so we've got the
pad of on sequence which is this is
based on you can build more cuboid
spiraling out forever and that's called
the
on spiral and I mentioned a set of
points of the SIRT Zack's triangle this
is Zack's triangle here you've got a
triangle which is divided into six
similar copies of itself these values on
the edges here are powers of the square
root of the plastic constant and there's
two different ways of building this
triangle from similar copies of itself
and we have a fractal triangle based on
this it's two different similar copies
and they're scaled as in powers of the
plastic constant and we get this
infinite series as well which had never
been done before here's another set of
five points where all the edges here are
powers of the plastic constant and this
is a very weird configuration so I
figured what happens if I go to 3d I
found out that I could build K 1919
points we're all distances between
points where powers of the plastic
constant which apparently hadn't been
done and as a side note here's this
weird polynomial where the coefficients
are the same as the roots you need
there's only one solution you need the
plastic constant for it with sort of
three there's two recent pieces of news
this 15th way of tiling the plane with
Pentagon's was just found a few years
ago by some friends of mine actually and
also it's possible to divide a square
into similar non right triangles this is
the only way to do it with with 46 or
less triangles I actually paid for this
solution
I had a contest for whoever could do it
with less than
100 triangles they would get that number
of dollars
- number of triangles see so I had to
pay $54 for this solution the 12er root
is a solution to two problems using 12
if you want 12 circles to cover the
maximum possible disc you need this
constant and that's the solution if you
want to make the largest possible small
triangle for 12 points you need the same
constant I'm not sure if it's just
coincidence or something else for the
trip anoche constant it's kind of the
extension of the Fibonacci sequence
instead of adding up the last two values
you add up the last three and this value
is used for making the snub cube with
this polynomial up here is there
bah-bah-bah if instead of one you use
the golden ratio instead like this you
can get the snub dodecahedron instead
and that's say a order six polynomial
the second pissant number but what is
the facade number this these are the
roots of this polynomial here you've got
one point outside of the unit circle and
three points on the inside of the unit
circle and that's the definition of a
pissant number when there's only one
root on the outside of the unit circle
and this is the second largest 1r
there's one that's lower the plastic
constant is lower that's the only one
that's lower than this one and similar
to the plastic constant it leads itself
to this bizarre similar triangle
construction all these numbers are
powers of the square root of the second
pissant number which it hadn't been seen
before you can also build things called
the generate simplex where you've got
three point are five points which are
all at a constrained distance apart and
these numbers here they're all
the square root of the second Passat
number now I thought I might be able to
find more large values and there's a
table of things I looked at and
everything with a power higher than 4
seemed to be single purpose there wasn't
there was it was good for one thing and
one thing only this fourth one the
second Passat number this is the highest
order algebraic number that I found had
m''d spread applications
now here's a a simple matrix which has
this particular eigenvalue and when
brillhart looked at this in 1965 he
noticed that the continued fraction was
bizarre and he didn't understand why so
it turns out the reason why here's an
example well we'll take a look at a
similar route that's in the same number
field this discriminants the same raise
it to the 24th power of minus 24 and
compare that to e 2 pi times the square
root of 163 and you can see that the
numbers are very close to each other 432
decimals of accuracy it turns out that
the first one is used to make the leech
lattice and the second one is used for
the J function the connection between
these two was called monstrous moonshine
by John Conway and bouchard's proves the
connection between them and 1a Fields
Medal because of it using modular forms
I'm pretty sure this whole talk is just
a trivial extension of modular forms
taking this it's just taking the square
root and squaring the silver constant if
we take a look at triangulated graphs
and look at their polynomials you get
these points here and Berar I noticed
there was clusters around first the
golden ratio in green and this red value
here which is now called the silver
constant
not the civil ratio it's a different
thing using silver this is also the same
space as a heptagon the regular heptagon
uses these values the last sporadic
three in a row solution uses these
points all in the space of the heptagon
i don't know why it uses two heptagon
and here's something else I found with
the seven gone the 7 2 star and the 7 3
star you can Ness them together to get
this in a distance graph that has fairly
incredible properties another unit
distance graph that's more famous is the
Mo's our spindle that's in black here
the Gullah graph which I said at the
start is in blue here and they overlap
so I wrote this demonstration to see how
many overlaps I could get between moves
or in the Gullah graph and this guy
named Aubrey de Grey really liked this
demonstration he said I think I can
extend this and maybe solve the had
would ensure Nelson problem which is the
chromatic number of the plane and so I I
correspondent with them and he was
correct he solved one of the most famous
unsolved problems in mathematics just a
few months ago with this graph now I
made the mistake of thinking that the
square root of 5 and the square root of
7 weren't important and he proved that
they were and he used Mathematica to
solve the problem so the biggest
mathematical result of this year used
Mathematica oops and it's right here we
can also look at rationals which don't
have any algebraic numbers this is the
best known solution for four in a row
but these are solutions are terrible
24:25 they're only on two lines so I'm
pretty sure somebody can find a better
solution the best way of packing
tetrahedra was just found a few years
ago there it is there everything is a
rational coordinate on the other end of
things you have high
algebraic numbers and I found they're
pretty much useless for example here's
the algebraic space for Graham's little
hexagon everything is huge I found that
the original algebraic routes were
actually simpler to use so then in a
conclusion whenever you have a set of
points
try putting one at the origin the one at
one zero and then look at the root
objects and look at their determinants
try squaring them and if they simplify
in the same way you're in an algebraic
number field and you can probably
simplify everything a lot and get good
things with these nice properties so
there's gonna be a series of these
notebooks I prepared with I've got like
ten times as much petraeus here if
anybody would be interested in those you
can email me and I can send you that
series in those books and I can take any
questions